and prime minister if the new dominant
variant in this country
is more dangerous than the first one is
it really right that there are more
people out and about than during the
first wave and that the rules are more
lacks
is there not more that you could be
doing to keep people safe like you did
last year
and to sir patrick um you said that uh
this new variant of coronavare spreads
more easily but you haven't concluded
why
do you have any early theories as to as
to what's going on any
different competing possibilities and to
professor witte
with infections now going down um the
our lumber below
one are we actually at or even perhaps
past the peak of infections
sam we are enforcing the
uh law uh very stringently with
increasing toughness you'll have seen
uh what uh the home sector what pretty
had to say about uh
about fines uh we will do it we will
enforce the law we will make sure that
people
uh don't uh engage in activities that
would mean
uh mass transmission of of the disease
or substantial transmission of the
disease
but it depends on all of us depends on
everybody watching
doing the right thing avoiding
transmission that is
far more powerful and far more effective
in stopping the
uh the transmission of this virus than
than police action or
or new laws from uh from the government
and that's what it takes the
the rules are very very clear stay at
home uh
unless you know you have a very very
good reason uh for not uh
staying at home protect the nhs and save
lives i think the people
of this country really understand that
all the evidence is that they
uh they comply with uh the measures uh
when
uh when when it's necessary and uh when
we'll get it down and
as i said there are signs that this is
working but it's going to need continued
resolve and
determination in terms of the the why it
may be transmitting more readily and
people are looking at this you know in
laboratories all over the world for the
all of these variants
um i think one thing that we don't think
is is the cause is that people have a
higher viral
load and shed more virus we don't think
that's the case
um uh it may be that it binds more
um um solidly to the the the receptor
for the virus and gets into cells more
easily as a result of that
it maybe it grows more readily in
certain cell types
those are things that people are looking
at and and more information will come
but i think what we can conclude is
there must be some mechanism by which
it it it can it can actually um
say either bind or intercell somehow and
in terms of the
infection rate uh if you took the
country as a whole and just averaged it
overall the number of infections is
broadly going down
but it's at a very very high level and
it's extremely precarious and i really
want to stress this
a very small change and it could start
taking off again from an extremely high
base
and there are some areas of the country
and some age groups
in which it does not appear to be going
down for example in people 20 to 30
the evidence is actually it may still be
increasing in some parts of the country
so
it is not solidly going down and it is
very very high
so if it took off again it would do so
from a very high rate that's in terms of
infections
in terms of hospitalizations which are
delayed because of course people
get infected they get ill and then they
go into hospital the the uh
again for the country as a whole it's
broadly flat at the moment
uh still going up in some parts
particularly in
the northwest and parts of the midlands
for example
going down in parts of the east of
england south south east and
bits of london but that peak is not yet
definitely going down everywhere and
then deaths
which is the last uh thing uh that is
going to be delayed further so i think
the peak of deaths may well be still in
the future
uh so that it depends which beat you're
talking about but i cannot i'm just
going to go back to the first point
this is high very high and very
precarious
and if people starts took this moment
and said right that it is over
we would get back into very deep trouble
very fast and the nhs is absolutely
at the top of what it can manage if that
happened again we would be in really
really deep trouble